[Musique]
bon sang mélanie poquet non c'est
grégory ribéry veut dire jumeaux en
yoruba la langue africaine parler au
nigeria bénin et togo lisa kind et naomi
dias des soeurs jumelles ont choisi
comme nom de scène
elles se produisent à la fin de la
semaine sur la scène du prisme
d'elancourt et c'est votre coup de coeur
oui un coup de coeur inattendu grégory
car un jour cg déclaré bei en les
écoutant à la radio alors c'est en duo
les akan et naomi diaz deux soeurs elles
sont nées à paris d'un père cubain et
d'une mère franco vénézuélienne et s'ils
en ont ne semble peu connu en france
encore elles ont pourtant une très belle
reconnaissance à l'international elles
sont repérés par adel prins ou encore
beyoncé et la musique est un métissage
de la pop du hip hop de l'électro
hypnotique et des chants yoruba un
extrait le clash
[Musique]
dabi
alors ça c'est un extrait de leur
dernier album h et un album que le
public pourra découvrir au prisme des
l'encours des titres qui donne envie de
danser mille sauts il faut aussi tendre
l'oreille
elle chante des titres sur des textes
engagés chilly gonzales qui est
compositeur et musicien canadien mais
chelle négoce et l'eau qui est rappeuse
américaine et des mots simples et d'une
certaine michelle obama
l'ex première dame américaine alors
j'arrête avec les noms célèbres ce
serait réduire ses jumelles assez simple
collaboration et b i se sont avant tout
deux voix superbe profonde et sensuelle
leurs morceaux sont en mouvement avant
tout envoûtante
écoutez
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
soit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour les écouter direction le prisme
d'elancourt vendredi 12 octobre à 20h30
merci mélanie pour cette chronique on
vous retrouve dans un instant dans votre
émission le à 7,8 culture